[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui veut casser des planches où c'est
encore une histoire de toilettes je suis
au ski avec un pote
ouais on fait les beaux gosses bon ça ce
qui on va au restaurant d'altitude et la
frère ce soir mon frère que là elle a
fondu je suis très très bien
la fondue elle n'est pas dans mon
assiette aller dans mon slip suite au
match nul en commun et là je descends
les escaliers gratte savez sur 10
descend les escaliers grâce et la ferait
le moins au milieu des escaliers moindre
effort sa part ça s'arrête
1 pourquoi il ya une queue de castor et
là je vais chez les meufs les meufs
frères pareil une dizaine de matches
mais un peu moins mais une dizaine de
personnes 4 et la frère arrive mon tour
maintenant moi ça fait vingt minutes
tout j'attends je fais sur toute la
cuvette fourrure mais plaire c'est le
sens de la nonette c'était faux
le sort des toilettes je bois je sors je
vois mes 15 9 14 monde y met des
lunettes de soleil quand je suis au
milieu des escaliers j'entends qu'à
capter plus jamais revu dans la station
[Musique]
écoutez moi bien ma koffi donne moi ton
coeur les 700 personnes enfouies le jury
[Applaudissements]
a figuré
souper au coupé le contact vous nous
donnez papiers du véhicule en jeu je
vous donne la carte grise l'assurance et
le permis de conduire est pourquoi on
vous arrête pas du tout ce que j'aime
pas votre gueule donc achevé de casser
le cul actuellement pourquoi pas à la
limite mais après pourquoi le maire y
avoir accès et qu'est ce que la
nécessité absolue
c'est les deux choses qui me pose moi
question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]